there was fire green screens and a whole
lot of bows and arrows whenever jeremy
renner was filming his hawkeye cgi
scenes in the mcu movies oh this is why
we do what we do jeremy renner and
elizabeth olson make a pretty stellar
team side by side amid the rubble and
the green screen they support each other
filming which translates perfectly to
their relationship on screen they did
get to film in pretty real feeling and
detailed sets with little cgi added
giving the actors an opportunity to
really immerse themselves in the
environment when they both gave it their
all and really started showing off their
powers renner had to furiously whip out
those arrows but in reality the actor
mimed the action with cgi allowing him
to move so quickly every single bow pull
is real though and considering the actor
performed the action over a hundred
times a day the team set him up with a
kitted out bow that made it much easier
for him to work with you gotta help me
one
while jeremy renner is often wielding a
bow on screen and on the set for some
sequences the actors swapped the prop
out for a soft long blue pole the
perfect tool to hold and use to make
this special effects team's lives much
easier
luckily all the quivers in his bag were
real no doubt helping the actor's
physicality as he maneuvers all of this
equipment with the blue pole and green
screen background the team was able to
capture this feisty tarmac battle when
the two actors got up close and personal
that pole took a rest so the real bow
could take center stage once again it
says they don't hardly hit me one
hawkeye against all those outriders
hardly seems like a fair battle
there was a ton of work done on this
particular sequence before filming
renner had to work with the team to
establish very precise choreography and
blocking making sure all the key moments
were established so the team could mock
up the sequence in three visuals once
runner was set these eight limbed
outriders were tested and created in
different animation cycles allowing them
to steal the scene with their leaping
and acrobatic running when all the cgi
was added to finish off each of the
creatures got special retouching to make
them look just as evil as they do renner
got to fly solo as he filmed the
sequence which was probably for the best
it looks like he would have needed all
his concentration to nail this complex
choreo
as cool as it would be if jeremy renner
really was shooting arrows capturing it
all probably wouldn't work out so well
especially if he was actually standing
on top of the city this major sequence
required a full cgi landscape while
renner was actually performing in the
studio with a classic green screen only
to be placed on top of a skyscraper in
post not a bad deal regardless of where
he was renner totally commands the
screen and convinces us he definitely
could be flying high
luckily he didn't need to worry about
falling off a tower though
the age of ultron battle one of the
biggest we've seen in the mcu and does
it ever deliver jeremy renner battling
alongside his co-stars is chaotic but
luckily they had everything expertly
planned and choreographed the fact that
the attacks on the avengers were all cgi
made it a lot safer for the performers
for sure with the action of the movie
being larger than life renner and his
crew got to perform inside this giant
structure within their green screen
studio as tough as renner looks punching
away it's a totally different effect
without the vfx
not only did jeremy renner learn how to
shoot the bow and arrow he learned to
become one with the bow and arrow the
actor really needed to get comfortable
using his weapons in all kinds of
circumstances particularly chaotic ones
in the avengers without the cgi this
scene was particularly hectic the green
screen soundstage littered with upended
cabs and rubble
battling alongside the one and only
black widow looks impressive even
without the effects
the avengers film saw renner working out
ways to transform his bow from a single
used tool to an incredibly useful and
powerful weapon
without any effects the battle is still
chaotic not to mention all the
impressive moves and stunt they perform
themselves the choreography works its
magic in this epic fight while cgi amps
it all up with the finishing touches to
make this movie look so great
one of the biggest scenes in marvel
movie history gave us some pretty epic
establishing shots of the avengers team
just seeing the crew ready to face off
together is extremely powerful the cgi
added only makes it more impressive this
set was a sight to see in its own right
though it was set against a green screen
but they still brought the heat with
real fire and explosions all that smoke
can't have been fun to deal with at
least they were all outdoors let's be
real this team brings it no matter where
they're filming or under whatever
circumstances this is like a comic book
fan's dream to see that
jeremy renner really does know his way
around a bow the actor got real
comfortable with his custom lightweight
bow made to facilitate all these
incredible action-packed sequences the
actor really gets to show off his skills
whipping his bow around expertly facing
chadwick boseman while there were indeed
arrows in his pack none flew towards the
black panther actor and the two found
themselves able to really bring the fire
in this giant green screen surrounded
studio both had their work cut out for
them and looking at the final product
it's obvious neither of them gave less
than their absolute best and their best
is very good i'm glad i don't care when
hawkeye takes on iron man and captain
america's civil war he means business
hey clint amen with so much action
packed into civil war each of these
pockets were filmed separately so
hawkeye got to have some one-on-one time
with iron man himself though no arrows
were shot on the day there really was a
flaming truck in the background surely
adding to the urgency and chaos of this
battle no surprise the cars tumbling
down weren't there at all but renner
being the skilled actor he is could
still make us believe it with his
reactions multiple contusions detected
yeah i detected that too hawkeye is
quick but it's hard to be as fast as
pietro whipping onto the scene
luckily jeremy renner wasn't actually
clipped by aaron taylor johnson
instead the team records the pietro
actor going full speed while runner had
to move much slower combining frames and
adding the effects of pietro speeding by
allowed the team to capture these
incredibly smooth looking moments
hopefully that snow cushioned renner's
rough landing a bit because pietro's
sass definitely doesn't help you didn't
see that coming is it a bird
is it a plane nope it's jeremy renner in
a wickedly cool plane sitting safely on
the ground
understandably the actors stay safely in
studio when they need to film using
massive equipment
like planes for example it's incredible
how many places these actors go and what
they experience in all the confines of
their filming studio
safe house
looking back on hawkeye sequences
reminds us just how skilled the actor
has become with a bow or a long blue
pole that is depending on the day
whether he's working solo or part of the
larger group renter brings it just as
much as the cgi team does